[Applaudissements]
javier mosseri normes et en forme qu'est
ce qu'on a aujourd'hui
plein de trucs j'ai ramené un petit peu
de telenovelas elle faisait monter en
bocaux ou la gare aussi parce que ça
passe toujours bien dans une chronique
j'aime beaucoup et à la fin il y aura un
micro trottoir
il y aura des surprises aussi
on y va on commence avec les telenovelas
mais c'est toujours par tourner
évidemment ils adorent la 3 retournement
bien laver va nous faire un petit roi a
laissées petit est mort avec les
télénovélas je suis passé sur evans
10-dan alors eva luna c'est une série
qui se passe au mexique malheureusement
le doublage effet à boulogne-billancourt
avec un petit décalage horaire entre les
deux et ça se ressent un peu au niveau
du doublage d'aller voir que quand
l'élève commence à bouger leçon arrivant
tout petit peu après mais c'est discret
mais raconte-nous mon enfant comment tu
as réussi à s'échapper de ce lieu dans
lequel ton père te retenue
il a commencé à me chercher pour me
battre et ce dernier l'a j'ai remarqué
que les doubleurs été créatifs en termes
de dialogue mais en terme d' insulte
c'est pas encore ça toi ce que sept jeux
citrouille quatre salles de gars
regardez là un peu on dirait du beurre
fondu
dans la même série j'ai grillé la fille
qui fut une baston de la manière la plus
improbable du monde qu'avez vous s'il
vous plaît c'est n'importe quoi
ceuta et ses origines comme ça c'est
n'importe quoi moi après ça je suis
passé sur daniela attendrait la série
daniela passion pas sur la personne
alors c'est emile et jean michel maire
qui tripotait co écriture dans cette
série vous allez voir il ya deux
actrices qu'un viennent sur une vieille
embrouille qui avait entre elles
malheureusement il n'y a aucune des deux
qui veut lâcher la faire sauf une qui a
à peu près autant de conviction que j'ai
de barbe
c'est à dire pas trop trop
alicia bien ici à sétois bavardons comme
avant
et eva ont peu plus bavarde et comme
avant il s'est passé tellement de choses
mais enfin entre nous deux rien n'a
changé
allez viens hockey
[Applaudissements]
un vrai bon d'enchaîner j'ai passé sur
w9 enquête d'action
j'adore là je suis tombée sur
sheherazade une flic de choc qui prend
des cours de bagarres avec les hommes
histoire de se perfectionner un petit
peu malheureusement le cours de bagarres
s'est pas passé exactement comme elle
l'avait prévu mais ça se joue à deux
trois détails c'est subtil la jeune
femme doit affronter axel policiers à la
berri nationale dans un combat de boxe
d'une minute clint shéhérazade épuisé
tente de reprendre son souffle
je me dis qu'ils vont être enfin
pasquale flouté qui pensent que c'est
parce que son visage après était pas
serré la pauvre mais je te regarde avec
ça parce qu'ils y sont allés un mois je
me suis fait bienvenue chez vous sur tf1
j'adore alors le concept est simple un
des gens qui possèdent un gîte reçoivent
des visiteurs chez eux et à la fin de la
semaine ils reçoivent une note sur le
rétablissement
oui eh bah là il ya une hôtelière qui
était pas super contente de la note du
coup elle a exprimé son mécontentement
mais pas comme tout le monde l'aurait
fait ya encore des lacunes dans un
vocabulaire moquette sale alors là
je tombe des nuits je tombe des nues
parce que déjà je la vois pas en quoi
c'est le genre de truc j'aurais pu faire
un wayne ou les bills dit là on est bien
allé on est bien l'élever oui moi après
ça je suis passé sur la conférence de
presse de l'équipe de france un pérou
hier didier deschamps galéré un petit
peu à trouver les journalistes devant
lui tellement il y en avait un
aujourd'hui c'est un peu le contraire
n'hésitez pas trop là du coup l'ambiance
change un poil qui pose la première
question à didier personne je suis tombé
sur le journaliste de bing qui a eu la
chance d'être invité à sa première
course de presse c'était son moment mais
il a une petite galère avec sa question
eric sankharé de de binh sport j'ai
oublié ma question un jour dit ça
reviendra ça revient didier deschamps
c'est l'entraîneur de l'équipe qui a
gagné la coupe du monde mais quand il
dit fine le fort on dirait l'entraîneur
de l'équipe de saint rémy les chevreuse
avec l'objectif kelowna de finir premier
de notre eau pour se qualifier pour le
fun iphone pour moi de juin d'assurer
notre qualification pour le le fanal
fort
didier au look très fort je l'aimé allez
après ça je suis passé sur bfm paris 1
ce matin alors il ya un prof qui
dispensait des cours de vélo en histoire
de d'adopter les bonnes attitudes ça
c'est la surprise du jour est parce que
c'est un peu dangereux sur vendez pas la
séquence indiscrets et donc il
dispensait des cours de vélo pour qu'on
adopte les bonnes attitudes dans paris
malheureusement quand on suit les cours
de ce prof on a très vite envie de
reprendre sa voiture
s'il est un peu un peu chiant mais tout
fut ton bras gauche vas-y cole toi à
droite non non non non à toi ce temps à
lima le regard c'est capital peut te
lèves non pas comme ça là c'est pour les
piétons à no no no nano ztag simple tu
commencé à courir sur le haricot thierry
tiens prends ton boulot de merde moi je
rentre à pied c'est beaucoup on enchaîne
alors là c'est le médecin tranchoir
comme vous voilà je venais dans la rue
maintenant photo d'un chroniqueur jean
michel mr et j'ai demandé aux français
de me donner leur avis sur jean michel
maire alors j'ai ramené aussi jean
michel maire comme ça quand les avis
étaient pas super stylé jean-michel
arrivé par derrière et là les français à
changer un petit peu leur fusil d'épaulé
mais fois rien est-ce que tu connaissais
cette personne
jean michel maire qu'est ce que tu
portes but c'est un gros pervers il a
beau essayer de faire le jeune tu as un
petit vieux quoi tu trouve beau ben non
c'est pas du tout motif projet madame
est un compétiteur justement oui je les
aime assez ouais je me disais quoi donc
oui plutôt sympathique pas comme si la
liberté c'est pas du tout ce que disait
tout à l'heure c'est est-ce que tu
connais sont parfaits ouais j'ai rendu
sommaire dieu se prenant pour un jeune
il fait un peu trop le mec combat comme
chroniqueur cas sont enfin c'est pas top
pas mon délire du tour dix commencé ses
comptes il bat un peu vieux qu'est ce
que tu me dises au sol où gisaient beau
gosse et alors que les producteurs il
commet pas mal la tnt tête sympa ouais
j'ai aidé sympa est ce que vous
connaissez cette personne c'est le
monsieur qui parlent en permanence de
set up
qu'est ce que vous pensez nous qui parle
peut-être un peu trop de set up
qu'est ce qui vous fait rire c'est pas
le plus de roulement paiement bonjour ce
sont vous disais des choses bien sûr
évidemment elle disait qu'elle trouvait
super beau gosse par contre bien sûr oui
est-ce que tu connais cette personne
mais j'essaie il essaie de faire le beau
gosse mais il est vieux fnj jet ski avec
les gens et tout mais pas du times et
dans les ans je vois mon nom pour agir
monsieur temps qu'on prétend justement
qu'est ce que tu disais ça mais moi qui
étais beau grèce et tout et voilà enfin
12e dans les emplois voilà voilà
ouais c'est vrai c'est marrant c'est
drôle
[Musique]
ce concert si verser mon chéri